merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Dominique Verrien pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 6 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la vice-président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
cher Françoise mesdames les co-auteur
chers amis qui est Martine mes chers
collègues si vous le voulez bien comment
sont tout de suite par aborder le sujet
qui fâche les quotas je vais vous faire
une confidence je ne les aime pas
j'aimerais moi aussi que l'on puisse
s'en passer et que les compétences des
femmes soient naturellement reconnues et
leur permettent d'accéder au plus haute
responsabilités vous pourrez me
rétorquer que c'est déjà le cas et vous
auriez raison oui des femmes sont belles
et vient au plus haute fonction de notre
pays et plusieurs d'entre vous ici
présentes en sont l'exemple cependant
pour paraphraser Audiard il existe aussi
des poissons volants mais ils ne
constituent pas la majorité du genre car
le problème des femmes
c'est qu'elle n'ose pas revendiquer leur
capacité souvent parce qu'elles en
doutent elles-mêmes il semblerait que
pour candidater à un poste un homme ose
le faire dès qu'il coche 60% des
compétences requises une femme
80%. on trouve audacieux un homme qui
vient réclamer une augmentation de
salaire
arriviste une femme qui le ferait
heureusement nous en sommes de plus en
plus consciente et pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière une association
d'ingénieurs au féminin organisait un
séminaire pour apprendre à parler
d'argent des femmes qui achètent qui
comptent qui vendent qui compte combien
coûte qu'elle construisent qui ont fait
cinq ans d'études après le bac ont
besoin d'apprendre à parler d'argent
apprendre à oser demander ce qu'elle
pense mériter en 2023 mais il est vrai
que l'on ne dispose de notre liberté de
gérer que depuis le 13 juillet 1965 date
à laquelle le Parlement votait
l'autorisation pour les femmes d'ouvrir
un compte en banque à leur nom et à
travailler sans le consentement de leur
mari
en attendant
10 ans après l'adoption de la loi dite
Sauvadet le contenu est toujours pas
malgré l'instauration d'un quota de 40%
de Primo nomination et c'est
probablement là que le bât blesse les
sols primaux nomination on compte plus
un quand une femme est nommée pas moins
un quand elle s'en va et quand les
femmes sont présentes bien souvent elles
ne se le sont pas au poste les plus
prestigieux ce phénomène se vérifie dans
les trois versants de la fonction
publique cela a été dit mais c'est plus
d'un million d'euros de pénalités qui
ont été réglés par les ministères pour
ne pas avoir respecté les obligations
paritaires dans nos territoires en
compte que 20% de femmes occupants des
postes de directeur général des services
et seulement 15% des postes de directeur
général des services techniques dans nos
hôpitaux enfin c'est 75% de femmes mais
seulement 27% de directrices d'hôpital
là encore le quantitatif ne doit pas
occulter la réalité du qualitatif
pourtant il est impératif que les
employeurs publics faussent preuve
d'exemplarité car ils emploient
aujourd'hui environ 6 millions d'agents
soit 20% de l'emploi en France comme
cela a été dit aussi et 62% des femmes
parmi ces agents toutes catégories
confondues en rehaussant à 45% le quota
sur les primonominations mais surtout en
instaurant une obligation cumulative de
40% sur les emplois
occupés je suis convaincue que nous
aurons un véritable impact à moyen terme
en outre la publication d'un index de
l'égalité professionnelle permettra
d'objectiver les écarts de rémunération
et de représentation
afin de garantir l'effectivité de cette
obligation une sanction financière d'un
montant maximal de 1% de la rémunération
brute annuelle globale de l'ensemble des
personnels est prévu dans le texte je
sais Monsieur le Ministre que vous
voulez revenir sur ce sujet en calant
cette pénalité par décret pourquoi pas
mais je souhaite préciser qu'une
sanction se doit de rester dissuasive
sinon elle devient totalement
inefficace mais peut-être pourrez-vous
préciser mais d'ailleurs ça fait partie
des amendements qui ont été proposés et
acceptés par la commission ce matin donc
précisé dans ce décret que les sanctions
seront rendues publiques ce qui
permettra de mieux connaître les
administrations ayant des difficultés à
appliquer la parité soit pour les aider
si cela devait être par manque de vivier
soit pour les contraindre si aucune
raison valable n'apparaissait bien sûr
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
aurait pu être un peu plus ambitieux et
je m'adresse à ma collègue Martine
filleul nous aurions pu voir un peu plus
grand un peu plus vite mais je tiens ici
à saluer le travail de notre rapporteur
cher Françoise avec qui nous avons su
trouver un compromis pour un texte
équilibré et sans doute plus
opérationnel c'est là le principal car
l'important reste que la situation
professionnelle des femmes s'améliore et
que notre fonction publique se dote
d'une politique de ressources humaines à
la hauteur de cet enjeu j'en profite
également pour vous remercier Monsieur
le Ministre pour votre engagement
sincère sur le sujet ainsi que pour
votre volontarisme dans la construction
de ce texte et naturellement le groupe
Union centriste votera ce texte merci
chers collègues la parole est à même la
présidente Nathalie Delattre pour le
groupe du Rassemblement